it gave me this shirt today
congratulations thank you this is what I
get for doing game demonstration for a
Nintendo sorry I just I felt like you
were just really showing off there for a
second I'm just excited I was showing
off I don't mean to brag I'm just really
exciting to brag that's all these if you
want me to like bash something this
shirt like you can see like a line where
the screen printing happened so it's not
the best quality shirt I've ever owned
so little oh the regime joke fair
observation comedy
The Legend of Zelda breath of the wild
official game trailer Nintendo e3 2016
hi I'm Gregory so excited I'm in
telophase Elma uh-huh yeah my whole
family would sit and play ocarina of
time like huddled together trying to
figure out the water temple together
like it's called ocarina thousand
ocarina I don't worry about them kids
getting up all the time I have put all
the games on console have played almost
all the games on handheld I haven't yet
had the pleasure of playing the Minish
Cap last um B game I play was over e no
time
I'm up to date do we need to catch up
I do like Zelda though the overall story
dose ought to be a great movie oh yes I
remember there's an April Fool's prank
video about I know and I got so excited
and I was like it's finally time for
[ __ ] they're doing and then we got let
down
we got like this just April Fool's joke
this game has been delayed five
bajillion times everybody is is waiting
on your chance and needles because this
game keeps getting delayed and they're
not sure with how badly the Wii U was
doing a lot of people only bought the
Wii U for this game knowing it was gonna
be on this console and then we it was
just announced a month ago or so that it
was also gonna be double released on the
NX the next Nintendo console and so
people who did buy a Wii U for this all
the game are furious here's the thing
though I have a feeling that this game
is gonna make up for it I trust Nintendo
with my Zelda I do really do I'm really
hoping that they can make it worth our
weight I'd rather wait a while play
other games in the meantime and have a
really really you know mind-boggling
game then have a subpar game that comes
out a year after the next the last title
which unfortunately Skyward Sword just
felt not very memorable so this time
Nintendo really seems to be putting
their heart and soul into it doing a
little bit of an overhaul I'm really
excited to see this trailer and see what
they've what
show I concur with all your statements
Brianna white thank you very much let's
do this video
we were now
see that I had no idea what you saw
there's something about Zelda huh
open your eyes
Rico plink yeah we go
holy crap
you
you
whoo really get a little life as link-up
really it's really like you got a live
in this king
I don't know what it is about that
trailer but I almost wanna cry meet you
I know what was going on I just kind of
liked her I was so emotional right now
having watched that so full disclosure
guys I worked in the Nintendo booth as a
game demonstrator at e3 this year so
I've not only seen this demo five
bajillion times that people have played
it over the course the past three days
but I've also played many hours of it
myself but I never actually got to watch
this trailer and I'm so glad that I'm
sitting here right now and I got the
chance to do that because holy [ __ ]
that's what a trailer is supposed to be
elaborate more please I would love to
hear this for any Zelda fan that is
watching this trailer and recognizing
certain elements of it from what we can
tell and everything that I'm going to be
saying is nothing inside information
from Nintendo they didn't tell me
anything all I know is what I've played
of the demo and what I just watched
right here it looks like it's set in the
future because you have a ruined temple
of time there and you actually get to
climb up the temple of time which I mean
the temple of time was a 2d thing way
back in Ocarina of Time I mean to have
that same thing as a ruin however many
years in the future that's actually an
interactive object if every at every
surface I mean that's just it not only
respects and acknowledges your love for
the history of the game but it brings it
back and changes it and makes it a new
thing that's something that I feel like
Nintendo kind of forgot in the last game
is to respect the love that we have for
the Zelda franchise and for the history
of it and for the lore of it and then
there are these guardian things they're
like robots that are like how stuck into
the ground with like their tentacles and
I just like I need to know what they are
I got a no still don't know I fought one
in the demo killed it but I don't know
what it is and in the demo in the
gameplay demo there were no horses so I
didn't get to see any of that so I'm
very excited to find out
there will be at least some sort of
horse even if it's not aggravated poni
Rihanna I've come to a conclusion yes I
don't belong in this video I would love
your opinion as someone who only played
ocarina of time really yes seriously
because here's what I kept hearing when
I got was collecting feedback from
people's gameplay demos they were like
this reminds me of ocarina of time like
there really hasn't been a Zelda game
this immersive since then you know
ocarina of time really not only changed
the game for Nintendo but change the
game for games period people are when
they get to play this they sort of feel
that way once again just get the shivers
when I think about ok I think I got
something I think I got something
I really like how what's the word for
free free run free form open world open
oh yeah I really like how they expanded
the open world even more to the point
where you are living just the you know
most miniscule details of his life I
feel like at one point we might even
have to like go to the bathroom you know
as link when people play Zelda they want
to be linked
you know links like one of the coolest
[ __ ] people you know he was a super
smash bros i go for late he's a legend I
would want I would want to be linked
you know Linkous is like that that
character you root for you know
absolutely yes I had a little something
to say you always do why is it called
breath of the wild and this is not
something that I know but this is just
kind of what I'm thinking it looks like
high roll has fallen into some sort of
ruin it looks like the area that you got
to traverse in this trailer in this
gameplay demo used to be high ville
castle so some of the areas are that you
walk over are paved obviously there's
the temple of time that's fallen into
ruins and so it seems like it's all just
returned to the wild and the wilds have
taken over what used to be civilization
and so now link wakes up after a hundred
years slumber and he's like well what
the [ __ ] do I do I have no tools so the
first thing he does in the gameplay
picks up a tree branch and it's like
okay here we go
here we'll talk
pretty cool another thing about the
breath of the wild is like you said that
open-world feeling that freedom feeling
a survival aspect to it you get to hunt
like you saw him hunting a boar you get
to see him hunt he can hunt you can
shoot birds he can shoot lizards he can
kill almost anything living in the game
true and he can cook those ingredients
to make potions or food or you know all
manner of attributes though what I'm
worried about is is it gonna take up a
lot of time in the game cuz I don't want
to do that all the time I like the
adventure of like fighting people and
slashing up like weird-looking zombie
things here's how it seems to me and
this is something that I've kind of come
to terms with by playing the gameplay
demo over and over imagine there's an
apple in a tree okay
your objective is to get the Apple down
my first thought climb the tree get the
Apple other person's first thought jump
get the Apple other person's first
thought shoot the Apple down another
person's thought cut the tree down
another person's thought bomb the tree
get the Apple all of these people get
the Apple in their own way based on
whatever items they have in their
inventory and whatever their first
instinct is so the idea is in this game
Nintendo has created a world that is
completely versatile giving you the
freedom to do things the way you want so
you no longer have to do things one set
way no longer does a boss have a certain
way it has to be killed you can use all
the different tools at your disposal so
if you don't want to cook you don't have
to a lot of the items that you pick up
you can just eat it'll replenish your
health right then and there you don't
have to spend the time cooking if you
don't want to also stealth is a part of
this game yes you can go into a crouch
and you are very quiet and you actually
have a noise meter at the bottom of your
screen so you can see how much noise
you're making so you can sneak up on
certain monsters and there are certain
things that you can eat and you can
collect that'll make your stealth mode
even better even higher
harder to detect and so if you want you
don't have to collect armor or collect
you know better weapons you can just use
your strategy to sneak up on them and
it's just as valid and it will work just
as well this is a formula that Nintendo
has been panned for in all of the Zelda
games in that all of the puzzles are put
the key into the lock and done if
there's only one key for this lock but
no longer they've changed one of the
most fundamental things about Zelda and
that's just well sorry I'm really
nerding out on you guys
I I finished talking about this in my um
my III review on my channel you know I'm
glad to see with so much passion
enthusiasm I'm happy to see that this
game is making you happy I do not feel
the same unfortunately I respect it
totally
well I pick up maybe however I love that
you love it and that's all that matters
to me I love that you guys love it I
know you're watching yeah you guys are
involved I would say for those of you
that had given up on the Zelda franchise
or given up on Nintendo because of the
Wii U's failures pick it back up rocky
Fort Rock b5 this would be a game to
give it a chance get the chance to play
the gameplay demo like eight times
mmm like I did so um again you can just
check out my um my e3 blog about that
should I promote that for you now you're
just in I got it check he'll put a link
in the description below in the
description well Briana thank you for
making this video actually worth
something if you're new to the channel
yep
Briana white please you can't you know
no one can talk better about your
channel than you can can you explain
what your channels I have a let's play
gaming channel um I used to play with my
brother so it used to be called sibling
rivalry but I'm actually in the midst of
a name change which is pretty exciting
so hopefully I can get that name change
done within the next week or so so I
hope you check it out put your
suggestions down below don't do that
dad yeah
again all of that I do read them all
actually I read every single car might
get one that's Oscar those of you being
rude like sugar rebellion I see you